the only item we've got to consider is
an application for
a new premises license
chicken pizza hey
it's a new premises license for a hot
food
yeah he's actually my uncle and my name
is muhammad
family business okay so i'm in a meeting
here
okay yeah muhammad
muhammad yeah you're speaking on his
behalf
yes okie doke
right i'm councilor david german i'm
chair of the licensing panel and i've
got councillor
councillors thomas and but with members
of the panel
uh we have a legal officer a licensing
officer
and a democratic services officer and
another officer
who's just observing the meeting yeah
okay so you're okay with that yes
it's going to proceed all right so
what i'll do first is i'll ask our
licensing officer to outline the
application
and then we can ask him questions if we
need to and then i'll ask you to speak
and then any representations any
representation
will speak well you have to ask your
questions and then and then they can
they can uh put the representations
okay they're all clear
about how we believe paul
okay i think councillor also got a
question
yes
yeah can i say um that noise
wasn't in the background i i can't
hear properly with it when you were
speaking
uh your words were
very good there's some there's some
drilling or something going on in the
background is that
is that at your end oh no
heated up turn off now yeah
now it's okay we don't want any
background noise so we can we can all
hear
each other properly is is that okay
actually is he there so that's
one okay thank you
councillor walsh
check can i see is normal
i can't actually see the applicant are
we conducting a meeting we're just using
the applicant's voice
well we can do um he's not got his
camera turned on but um
i don't i don't think it's an issue
really
you don't believe that's an issue okay
no okay
well can i ask the legal opportunities
his camera
i'm sorry that you've got quite a bit of
an echo as well but
no there's no issue with him having the
camera turned off
okay yeah all right then
um karen sure is jack and i say
can i have it recorded that i do feel
uncomfortable that we can't see
the applicant's face it may be legal
that we can conduct the meeting with
just the
the applicant being able to speak to us
but i really don't think it's uh
in the spirit of the meeting that the
applicant
has his camera switched off i really
don't think so i'd like that miniature
check
mr irfan yeah but a problem with turning
your camera on
i did turn off shall i try let me go the
opposite i could turn it on i mean
would you be happy to turn it on yeah
sure let me
check with the option ago yeah
on camera off to be honest before it's
fine
so yeah now okay okay that's fine
thank you okay cheers
okay um right we're happy to proceed now
um mr hinchcliffe would you like to
outline
the application before of course yeah
uh so my name is kieran himself i'm the
licensing officer in the tropical
application for a grant of a new
premises license under section 17 of the
license act 2003
outside chicken and pizza 680
chester road in stratford
i'll just go through this um this report
if if i'm able to i'll just put
the mute on for for all participants
um it'll take a bit of time just to go
through and then
normally
natalie are you able to control the mute
facility
or or yeah actually if a goal is not my
first take
okay um
so i'm just going to go through the
particulars of the report and then we'll
the chair will take control of the
meeting again so
um the the under section 18 of the
licensing act 2003 members are requested
to determine this application for a new
premises license
at 680 chester road having regard to the
representations that have been received
and the requirements promote the four
licensing objectives
the following options are open to the
licensing subcommittee this evening
you can grant the application in full on
the terms and conditions contained
within the application
and to include any applicable mandatory
conditions
you can grant the application as a
public modifier to such an extent as
considered appropriate to satisfy
any relevant representations and promote
licensing objectives
or you can reject the application before
a promises license is required in
respect of any premises where it's
intended to conduct one or more of the
four licenseable activities these being
the sale of alcohol
supply of alcohol respected club
premises regulated entertainment
and of course the provision of
late-night refreshment the application
was submitted by mr by sahil moosa
on behalf of mr mohammed aslam in
respect of 680 chester road
the applicant initially applied for the
following hours
and that was late night refreshment from
2300 hours till 2 a.m
monday to thursday on friday and sunday
would be until 4 00 am opening hours to
match
that application was properly made and
all the procedures were correctly
followed
the application included an amended
operating schedule
and that was attached to appendix a as
part of the application
[Music]
photographs of the blue notice in place
and copy the newspaper
are also included as appendix b in terms
of background history of the premises
the premises is not currently licensed
and the applicant has described
the premises as a hot food takeaway
for the operating schedule that's
completed by the applicant and it
contains additional measures to
illustrate how they propose to promote
the four licensing objectives as
required by the provision of the act
they're listed below from 3.1 downwards
and they'll be attached
as conditions to any license as may be
granted
chair i'd like to um to take your um
your attention to um the
license condition at number eight which
says
uh no deliveries or collections relating
to license activities that the premises
will take place between the hours of um
4 a.m and 11 o'clock
i mentioned that only because there's a
there's a
there's a contrast or a conflict in
hours now in terms of
what the applicant has agreed as an
amended application
at the times which we'll discuss later
on and what
the times actually appear as in that
particular condition
so you may want to consider consider
condition eight to match those hours up
okay so following the consultation the
council's environmental health officer
um the application was further
amended to remove hours for outdoor late
night refreshment
and also the following hours were agreed
this is attached to the suspended seats
your application
and the amended hours are 2300 hours
to midnight and that's for both the late
night refreshment indoors
and for the opening hours so seven days
a week is what's been applied for
uh with no seasonal variations and it's
2 300 hours till midnight for
late night refreshment indoors only in
terms of the consultation
the responsible authorities were
included and they
are a great manchester police pretty
much to fire rescue they're all detailed
listed in 5.1
now of those consultees identified one
representation was received from another
person
that was counselor lawrence walsh he's
concerned with fly tipping at the site
and the hours that were applied for
councillor outlines his grounds
for concern under the licensing
objective of the prevention public
nuisance
and he requests the subcommittee to
amend the hours to 2300 hours to
midnight
on saturday and sunday only and he also
assists the assurance of a robust waste
removal policy
that representation has been attached to
appendix c
the representation as as mentioned
earlier on from the policing control
authority they're a responsible
authority and that's attached as
appendix see
that representation was satisfied by the
agreement amending the hours
of opening and the late night
refreshment indoors only to 2300 hours
to midnight
seven days a week a copy of the report
and representations received
has been sent to the applicant and those
that have made representation have been
formed at the date and time of the
hearing
in terms of legal considerations finally
chair conditions may only be attached to
a premises license where they are deemed
appropriate
for the promotion of licensing
objectives they must be proportionate
and not duplicate any existing
provisions contained within other
legislation
and a justification behind a refusal all
the attachment conditions must be given
to the applicant
um there is a right of appeal to the
magistrate's court for any decision
that's made
from a following being notified from the
decision or licensing subcommittee
that concludes the the outline of the
report chair i'm happy to take any
questions from you or any of the members
okay thank you does anybody
have questions
wish to ask
no okay okay can we
sorry can i ask a question please yes
yeah
it's just to do with the uh the the
hours uh
are these hours similar to what uh they
are on the other
very similar kind of takeaways enabling
on that front row front
um i believe there was a check by one of
my colleagues a licensed officer
and and they they they proposed
um similar hours there was there was
only one other
um premises that was identified in the
area being
harry ramsden's which i know is some
distance away
we don't have any details of any other
premises there is is there any you would
particularly want me to check
how quickly could you do i mean it'd be
good to have an idea of what the
uh our operating hours are for the uh
the other similar kind of
uh outlets in that particular block
you're more than welcome to bring in
your own you know area knowledge and
local knowledge of the area
um but in terms of like the council's
policy
the the council's uh licensing policies
is for each application on its own
merits
so you do need you do need to um focus
on
the individual application we don't have
like a broader policy for
for certain hours for certain premises
and so there's there's not
necessarily like a box for it to fit
into although
although that may make some level of
common sense it's not a policy of the
council we're more directed to dealing
with each application
on its own merits there um so
particularly what the area
what the concerns of the area has been
raised by council walsh
and how that contrasts with um the hours
and the conditions that have been
applied for
this evening that's what's um that's
well that's what your your remit this
evening is for
okay okay thank you
yeah so originally the applicant applied
um so that there's a there's a
chronology to this application as it's
coming
so there was a there was a submission
from the applicant
and and what was applied for was 4 a.m
on friday and sunday friday saturday
sunday
and then 2 a.m monday to thursday
so that was what was applied for um we
have a twin we have a statute as you
know we've got a 28-day statutory
consultation period
you responded um as another person we
also had a response from
the council's environmental health they
take up the position of a responsible
authority
now from contact with the responsible
authority
the applicant has amended the hours that
they were applying for
so what we're now considering is the
hours
um from 2300 hours until midnight
seven days a week so the application
that you've now got i know this
it started out in contrast to that
but for this evening you're considering
um 2300 hours until
until midnight and of course in terms of
the representation that you submitted
council walsh um your position was
it should be 2 300 hours to midnight um
at the weekend only so there is a there
is
there is still debate to be had and
views to be put forward
you okay with that thank you for that
can i can i just just talk a little bit
more okay what
what what we're talking about late late
night refreshment
from 2300 hours to midnight
what are we talking about there what
what's the difference between
that and the operating hours of 11 00 11
in the morning so 12 o'clock
midnight what's that what's that one
hour
late night refreshment
what that detail is
okay uh the the detail so from
um the the only part of this uh the only
the only actual remit here that's that's
actually licensable
is late night refreshment late night
refreshment is the sale of hot food
or hot coffee so um for they've
described their premises as
um a hot food takeaway and perhaps the
applicant can expand on what types of
food
they sell you know for all intents and
purposes this is
this is the takeaway a late night
takeaway so
the uh scope of the licensing act 2003
is that if they sell hot food after 11
o'clock
then that's licensable and they need the
need an authorization through the local
authority to carry out
activity and in getting that that
authorization we have to satisfy the
licensing objectives
which which are the prevention crime
disorder the prevention public nuisance
public safety and the protection
children revolve so that
that's just your scope throughout this
meeting
we're happy to clarify it re-clarify it
and then the
the decision-maker the elected members
of the decision makers they can draw
upon the actual legal adviser
um following the the the end of this
this meeting thanks for that
thank you that's fine yeah thank you
we've actually agreed with the
environmental health of less hours than
you
you were asking for in effect so
hopefully that will satisfy the the
hours situation
so um is there any more questions for mr
hinchcliffe
can we move to the applicant mr irvan
is it is he there this is on mute
mr erfan you're on mute
hello
mr irfan
yeah just while he's he's sorting out
his music might be because um
our democratic services officer put him
on me
natalie can you unmute him or just just
a point of clarification
can you hear me now yeah we can hear you
now just hang out
[Music]
we have the environmental health have
agreed 23
100 hours till midnight monday
to sunday so that's seven days a week
the representation
the representation that's mean is it
like twelve or two
and the uh i'll answer that let me just
say so
i i'll finish these two points and if we
need to clarify i will do
and effectively it's it's 2300 hours so
11
at 11 pm till midnight uh monday to
sunday seven days a week is the
application before us now because that's
all the hours that were agreed with the
environmental health officer and that's
what made the application
the representation that we still have
outstanding from
um councilor walsh is is the is those
hours
uh the suggestion the proposal in that
representation
is to limit the hours further from 2 300
hours until midnight
on the saturday and sunday um and also
um for a a a robust waste removal policy
those those are the two
the two um contentious issues at the
moment
does that match your understanding on
behalf of the applicant
yeah actually i just need something
actually
my work experience because it's not my
first takeaway i go already are running
to take veda which is the sun tennis and
vegan
so because basically that you can heard
about san tell's council
by late night that that both permits now
go for
permission for three four in the morning
so i
do underst i don't understand what
experiment you need so
uh i don't selling any alcohol it's an
old call lesson it's only for hopefully
okay i think i think you know if i if i
just
um just go back to it are you happy
there's no any more questions from me
are you happy with that we can move on
to the applicant
okay yes sir
it's your chance now to speak to your
application
yeah actually i just i just yeah i just
need to say something because i go
experience so
they are running two takeaways already
so that's my third one
so they already did go go late night you
know
so i like appreciate if you know an
issue to late night last month if you
can do please
is no i don't selling any alcohol it is
only hot food i do you understand
only hot food no alcohol
yeah yeah yes
so i do they they did accept you give me
the after answer like
11 a.m to till 12 or 11 a.m to till two
in weekdays monday to sunday but friday
such a day four
so i do already requirement
i'll go binge everything i know how to
handle it so
it's up to that's what i'm saying so my
side is everything is fine
right so you we've agreed you've agreed
the hours
with with the environmental health
office until midnight
what what sorry i don't understand 2300
hours like i mean 11 to 12 midnight
because that's all you need to license
is from 11 o'clock 2300 hours
okay that's when it starts the
licensable
activity until now which i think i think
i think you might is probably not
understanding the fact you extended the
hours they've been extended from 2300 11
o'clock to 12 o'clock
midnight oh yeah is that what that's
what you said isn't it yeah that's
that's means 7 day 11 to 12 yeah
yeah yeah okay okay so they
know any chance like good morning
yeah okay that's fine i understand you
do 11 to 12 17.
but i need to request is any chance like
11 to 2 or no
no that's not what's been agreed okay
that's why that's still happy 11 to 12
let's see after i can do
application well we'd have to put a new
variation in
if you wanted to do that um okay
so do you want to tell us a bit more
about the operation
what sort of food you say no that's fine
i don't understand if you
because all your requirement i can do
like late night but
still what can i do because i go shop
there anyway
so i have to do business there you know
i hope their own they
i see the chester road more sharp they
open late at night
i see some they're still four in the
morning or three in the morning
they don't traffic to our council you
know so
can you tell our elected members about
your business
and what you want to sell and how you're
going to how you're going to run that
business
you're obviously talking about the hours
at the moment but our members need a bit
of an idea of what what your business
actually is because you've already
described it as a hot food takeaway
yeah so you just give them a bit more a
bit more
um a bit more detail for your
application i'm sure they would value
they would value that yeah i'll go the
between
you want to address my new other
takeaways so
if you need rest because i do already
late nights i do only hope food like
chicken and pizza
food is only food selling you know so
deliveries though
you can't open after 10 anywhere these
days but
only for hot food chicken and fast food
that's it
nothing else
right so chicken and pizza did you yeah
things like that yeah we do do we don't
do kebab yeah we do chicken pizza and a
doughnut
three things we do only some chips
yeah chips yeah yeah salad and all the
usual
yeah yeah okay
so that's only four or five things what
was happening you know so
that's where i can't say any more things
okay right so i'll open it up to
questions then so if anybody has any
questions
does anybody have any questions of the
applicant at this stage
yes check in yes votes counselor but
uh yeah it's one that uh councillor
walsh was raising you know about the
uh uh the waste what actions
uh do you expect to take i mean uh
leaving out the
the other takeaways you've got in other
boroughs uh i mean obviously
trafford has got high standards so we
try and maintain our standards here
and we just want to know um
well something i want to know what your
intentions are or how you are going to
manage
the waste
in that area you know which is com comes
from you there
so or you know people that
perhaps frequent that place
we go two bins in the back we contract
with varied draws
they come every friday morning they do
collections
we'll go to a big bin in behind my shop
so every night whatever
we put there so every friday morning
they collect from us
and are they full or uh
they're not there's no food because
depend on the business is it quiet or
busy but
i don't think so these two been gonna be
full because one they do general waste
and one they do just paper and
cardboard so i don't think so they every
week they're full
so every friday morning doesn't matter
the full of the half
they have to collection every week i
collected from the front or the back
hey actually thursday night they're
gonna move the in the main road you know
right side so they can pick from them
there is a highway back side
you know i can my door can open and i
can put on the side so every friday
morning they pick from there
so then when they go then i bring it
back inside so the the street the back
street's
not gonna yeah yeah so it's not gonna
it's not gonna have any
uh rubbish there or no no no no because
it's the bin in it so the
move the bin there or rubbish whatever
is one bag or two bag or state
we put in the bin we don't put on the
side or anyway we know
okay thank you jeff so thank you you're
currently open at the moment
are you without a bit of a late license
yeah so you're running as a business at
the moment
yeah we closed 10 o'clock because it's
you know it's locked down so
10 11 o'clock to close okay yeah
right so so at the moment that that fin
collection once a week is sufficient is
it
yeah one once a week here right and do
you
what about litter outside or in the
alleyway how do you deal with that
the sorry deal one second or later if
customers might not be from your shop
but if people drop
pizza cartons and paper chip paper i
don't
i don't think so there's anybody dropped
it because my bins in my instead of door
i go private door there so we open only
once
when we put out then we lock the door so
i don't see any rubbish in the hallway
so there's none in the alleyway either
no okay can i come in dave when you're
free
yes i'm pleased thank you mr
fan i've got a couple of questions for
you um
first off um you you've just mentioned
about bringing your bins out from your
back alley
and putting them on the main road on
thursday night for them to be collected
on friday morning
yeah that that concerns me as uh people
could
uh tip them out uh damage them
uh as a quantum vandalism would it not
be better
and perhaps better for the street scene
to uh
take your bins out on a friday morning
yeah that's fine and that i won't gonna
do next time
i can speak with them contract with very
draw so i can tag them please they
because it's door open because i tell
them they can do the self take out and
they put back here that's gonna do it
don't move anymore right yeah
that's that that that would be better i
think from my thank you
also uh council will ask you about
litter from
people that come into the shop and buy
food from you
what what have you put outside for your
customers if your customers go outside
the residents around your shop and in
the back areas
don't want them disposing of the litter
on the floor so it blows all over their
estate
and where they live what would you do do
you have do you go out and
make sure that your litter from your
food stuff
is collected and either put into the
public bin or put into your own bin
or do you do not do that does that not
does that not concern you
uh because to be honest because if the
customer coming inside
we go because we go we'll go next door
subway
and we go all three four shops same like
uh
far take away yeah appreciate that yeah
i've got three four be in front of
my shop i can see three four bins there
so i don't think so the customer's gonna
be put in the floor so they put in
the bins yeah no i'm just saying would
you
maybe maybe beneficial to have a check i
would hope that
subway and all the others are mindful of
uh people that drop litter
finally um regarding the license you
you've mentioned a couple of times that
friday and saturday you would prefer
till two o'clock
yeah you agreed or the the license has
been agreed or with the licensing
officer
to to 12 o'clock and that's been agreed
uh
at this meeting now you're asking or
saying that you prefer it to be two
o'clock
yeah i just don't know but that isn't at
this meeting i don't think that this
is going to be an option for you so can
we can we be
safe in the knowledge that if it is a
busy saturday evening or a friday
evening that at 12 o'clock you are going
to stop serving
yeah i'll stop serving because i've got
12 i can't do after 12 minutes
but yeah i know that i just want to be i
want to be sure that uh
that if we say that 12 o'clock he's
going to be the hard fast rule
yeah if it's 12 is mean 12 we can do
what we do 11 45 for
half lemon if we're very busy or stop
doing order
okay that's fine thank you thank you
thank you very much
thank you council thomas uh anybody else
uh
councillor walsh have you got any
questions for the applicant
just questions at this yeah i've got
more questions but i'm hoping i'm going
to be able to make a representation
because he will do
after this if you've got just questions
of what what the occupant said and then
you can you can say your piece
yeah yeah
carry on have you got questions
if if you haven't you can we can just go
on straight on to you
unless there's any more questions for
the applicant we can just go straight on
to your representation
is that okay yeah right we'll do that
then
okay carry on um
can i say chair that i speak out of
frustration
for many many years myself and the
residents have seen fly tipping
at the rear of those shops
at chester road and um
it it's it's no little matter and we've
had the council must have spent a lot of
money
removing litter over the years and uh
if you've read my representation i'm
sure you have
um people will say it's not my litter
and the premises and the businesses will
say it's not my litter
but the letter is there deleted very
very frequently
and uh i would rather
see a robust
stating how the applicant is going to
remove his letter
and i i don't doubt he's
he's good intentions and i want his
business to be a success
but with respect
council thomas question and he changed
his policy there
just by talking to him now i need to see
and the residents need to see a document
that states
how waste is going to be managed
do you know because it and that that
document
is going to be treated with respect and
is going to be adhered to
and and it's it's available for
residents to see
and i don't feel what the applicant's
despite his best intention doesn't give
me that confidence that he's got such a
document
and i i'm wondering whether under our
licensing regime
within the council whether we can ask
for
such a document or robust document that
states
how waste will be removed that is that
is
litter at the front because people will
throw this off the floor
they want to be targeted
and we do not have three cleaners at 12
o'clock at night
and litter that accumulates in the rear
how will that be removed because there
will look little find its way there
and the general collection of the
applicant's
waste materials how that is processed
what time have you been go out you know
keeping a record of taking place
properly
so is it is it come can we ask for a
document that states how
waste will be removed well we can make
it a condition
if you have a mind to it
there's not very much in the operating
schedule only about um
his waste being taken away once a week
which we know about
you can make a condition
the council's produced model conditions
um page 151
of that statement of licensing policy
there's a subheading
which is littering cleansing and at 90
it details um some form of
um of condition that could be suitable
reading it vibatim it says at specify
times specify
areas outside the premises including
specified areas must be swept or washed
and littering sweeping's collected and
stored
and then you can specify storage and
collection so
and then it also goes on at 91 for all
takeaway packaging wrappers
she'll identify the premises by way of a
company local name
and some other some other um some other
model conditions for littering cleansing
so you do
you do have have scope there um
alternatively you know you you also can
have scope to
um to demand something of of of the
applicant if it's
if it's you know not been presented um
for you we've obviously not received
anything so far
okay can i can i just ask me out well
what what
i can't hear you i can't hear you sir
sorry what time is your refuge collected
on the friday
eh the morning about i think i see
i did i can't mention that 10 but i
think the early morning 10 11 i think so
10 about 10 11 o'clock yeah
okay thank you thank you thank you very
much
councillor walsh did you have any
questions
i don't see the applicant's answer as
maybe 10 o'clock
as as as a robust statement on how waste
is going to be removed i
i have to say that and and and and i say
i asked i emphasized to everybody in
this meeting
uh and i'm sure you're aware of it we
are talking about our premises that are
very very close
to manchester united's football grounds
no doubt the license officers will tell
me that it's got nothing to do with
it but the residents at the rear of
these premises have had to put up with
a lot of anti-social behavior for many
many years and it
got to the stage where the alleyways are
used as a toilet on occasion
and the residents are very very
frustrated by that and they do not
want additional problems
caused by new businesses it's as simple
as that
i don't think it's fair on the residents
for us for us to ask them to put up with
any more
convenience and so
i asked again for the committee
if i've not asked before can we ask the
applicant
if you like grant the application
tonight with a proviso
that gives us a document which is a
robust
has statements in it that say how his
waste will be removed
that are accurate that are logical
and that they will be adhered to and
they will be able
the residents would be able to view them
if they needed to be
i don't think that's um unreasonable
chair
and we need to talk about the fronts i
say again counselor thomas mentioned
people will throw litter in the street i
don't think it's reasonable
for litter that's not it's not the
applicant's fault
his customers throw litter in the street
it's left there
and it's not picked up there's plenty of
businesses i know who send somebody out
with a sweeping brush
and they sweep up when they're closing
they take all that litter
that that possibly they've accumulated
some their customers have accumulated
while they've been open to leave the
place clean
okay i mean we can take that on board
with the conditions we can have some
robust conditions so
i i can't preempt the discussion but but
we'll certainly be discussing that
so we can we can deal with on on the
conditions
okay can i can i continue chair it's
going to continue
i have a suspicion that there'll be
people turning up at the applicant's
takeaway
the worse for where they'll be
intoxicated
have we has as the applicant produced a
policy
on how we will deal with uh with
customers like that
not the applicant's fault but we all
turn up intoxicated
do we know does he not understand how
he's going to deal with that have we got
documentation
to say how he's going to do that he's
got plenty of experience i'm sure he
knows what to do
i'd like to see some documentation
around that
right i'm just trying to see if there's
anything in the operating
conditions can i just ask some new
councillor walsh on this one please
uh council walsh you know you obviously
chair planning and
when you approve applications and
they've got conditions
to do with removing things or
how they're going to behave and we get
many of complaints from residents saying
that
you know things are being strewn and
they're doing that have they
signed documents to say that they're
going to be doing this doing that
can you just sort of confirm i think if
you produce a document counselor
that says for example this is how we
will deal with
customers who are intoxicated i think
there's more of a propensity on the
applicant
to deal with it in that way if we just
say well
you know we'll just sort it out on the
night that's a bit too vague
the location of the premises close to
the football ground
close to the public houses i think
that's going to be an issue
and the background to it is that would
cause disturbance for the residents for
the neighbors nearby
yeah can i can just talk a little bit
further this thing with a little chair
it's not just a case of the thing
looking nice and tidy
there's a health and safety issue here
when you're walking about
and this little old strewno about the
place
you know that's a danger people slip on
that you know
a tray perhaps it's had a food in there
that's greasy
very easy to slip over in the alleyways
at the back
i can tell you the litter that i've seen
thrown down you can see the pictures
the applicant can see can look he's
welcome to do that
the pictures that i've taken in recent
time that litter constitutes a health
and safety issue
so i i think um it's not just the
local council of being fussy about
litter there is a health and safety
issue
and you know families are entitled to
use that alleyway as well
they're they're entitled to to to walk
to and from the rears
but they can't do that when there's lots
of litter and
fly tipping that's taking place then
so so how often would you like to see
the litter
cleared up outside the
think the business needs to clear all
its litter away every every evening
chair
every time it closes the business i
don't think that's a reasonable
okay
can i just ask it's probably too just um
um typo check but in the application the
check the
applicants wrote his address but i
didn't see a postcode in there
and presuming the applicant has given
his full address
uh perhaps we do that it isn't produced
for the
for the safety of the applicant which i
can understand but when i looked in his
application
he gave his home address it just said
online of his address
it didn't give up or anything like that
got his telephone number his email
but we don't have his full uh postal
address
that's what you're referring to
to help with that i think it's because
on the
actual application forms um
it gets separated out so there's a
there's a residential address
it just appears there's one line well
then there's there's another couple of
boxes that say
post town and house code so it probably
looks as though he's not completed
but we do have um you know wiggin and
wn4
9se as a as a license holder that's
public information
thanks for that i'll just finish this
one with another point
excuse me counselor excuse me councillor
walsh can i can i just reject
on the matter of the application there's
there is a postcode for the wigan
address but there's no telephone number
for the shop
on the front of that uh kieran i don't
know if that makes a difference
um it's it's really fairly applicant to
provide what contact number they want to
provide sometimes we see it as the other
way around
um with the you know wanting a contact
number for
uh for an individual there you'll know
that because he's not selling alcohol
we don't have a designated premises
supervisor
um so generally it would just be the
shop number so to have a mobile contact
on bris
is probably better you know if he wants
to provide a different contact number or
if you if you want that whole thing then
then we can definitely i'm sure you know
the applicant's not going to be having
an issue with that
you know i'm sort of speaking on his
behalf i do apologize
yeah i know
apply for milasana i think he give his
number in it
because he's dealing with the console so
that's why give his number you can take
my number if you wanna know what it is
to display in the shop
or to give to residents
yeah zero nine six yeah
nine eight nine right okay
thank you councillor walsh is there
anything else
you wanted to say yes please check i'm
grateful to mr evan for that
if the residents have got a telephone
number that they can ring and raise any
concerns they've got
that that's um it was very very useful
i'm very very grateful for that
um there's lots of takeaways in garcia
ward
and um particularly at the area where i
live in ghost hill
there is the some of the takeaways do
stay open longer than the permitted
hours they've done that
for uh for a long time and uh what tends
to happen is
one of the takeaways will stay open just
that little bit longer
and then the takeaway next door will
think well i'm
going to lose business here so i'm going
to stay open
that little bit longer and so it gets
into there's a bit of a contest between
how long they stay open for and it just
emphasized to mr irvan that
and and he did talk about that before he
he understands that
but we don't want those takeaways going
up you know
opening longer than the the permitted
hours it just sets a trend and uh
and and people other people seem to
follow it and
just sets a bad example for the area but
thanks for his help so far chair and
then
thank you for allowing me to speak okay
point well made
and does anybody have any questions for
councillor walsh
right okay can you just sort of sum up
now it's the time
we ask the the the applicant and the
representative to sum up and it's
the representator first which is
yourself so just basically sum up what
you're saying about the application
please that's the walls
i know your risk of repeating yourself
thank you
i won't do that i'll try i'll try not to
do that
we want we want the best for the
businesses we want mr irvan's business
to succeed that's what i want i want
people employed there and to do well and
then to provide a service out i'm sure
i'll be calling in some time
for a takeaway there that that's great
it already is
we've had problems with some takeaways
in the past
and i do feel that the residents in
this particular area if they've suffered
enough and i want to look after them
what look i'm i want the mr irvan and
the neighbors
to get to get on like a house on fire
that's that's why i'm speaking tonight
so the the things that i've talked about
are to help that
you know i plan to pick up the litter
you know a contact number
i'm grateful to councillor thomas a
contact number for people to ring
you know if there are any issues
and and that we keep talking mr uravan's
always welcome to
to phone me and uh i'll happy to phone
him
and then we work together for the
betterment of the area
because when the area improves that'll
be better for mr urbadan's business as
well
and he will do better in in in a nicer
environment so he benefited as well as
the residents
i'll shut up there now chair thank you
thank you councillor walsh yeah i think
it'd be a benefit if you do
swap numbers you've obviously got mr
irfan's number you can
hear with that outside the meeting
obviously
um mr irfan would you like to stop
your application please in conclusion
just stay tuned just say some final
words about your application in
conclusion
no that's fine i'm i'm
i'm okay you're happy with that oh okay
thank you very much
okay then in that case i'll ask
natalie to put us in the breakout room
and we'll uh we'll
we'll make a decision on the on the
application and then
and then come back into the main meeting
thank you very much have a nice evening
sir
just you just hang on and we'll uh we'll
debate it and then come back with the
decision if you want to wait
wait on for that no that's kind of it
okay
yes lovely okay thank you
yeah okay we're gonna grant you
i'll insure
can you just repeat that again i think
this equine maybe the applicant needs to
switch his uh
the speaker off yeah can you can
everybody switch any background noise
though
yeah okay there's no background noise
all right then okay i'll start again
hello
okay i'll start again during the hours
of operation of the premises
the license holder shall ensure
sufficient measures are in place to
remove or prevent
litter or waste arising or accumulating
from customers
in the area immediately outside the
premises
and near of near to the premises and
that these
areas shall be subject
and litter and sweeping shall be swept
on litter and sweeping collected
and stored in accordance with the
approved
approved refuse storage arrangements
by close of business so basically swept
up and put in the bin
before you finish for that that night
so you will be written to with the
uh the condition in black and white
which is
basically a normal condition for any
business so you will be allowed your
application
until till midnight every night seven
days a week
with that condition
okay you understand yes i'm okay with
that
okay in that case i will uh i will close
the meeting
okay i wish you every success with your
business thank you very much sir
you're welcome okay have a nice day and
you
first of all bye-bye all right then
okay everyone